simplifica 25 a kubica a kubica elevado
al cubo de cuadrada dividido entre 5 a
cuadrada b&b cuadrada esto lo podemos
hacer de diversas maneras simplificando
distintas cosas lo que yo quiero hacer
es simplificar a kubica elevado al cubo
para esto va a ajustar esa propiedad de
los exponentes que nos dice que a kubica
elevada al cubo es lo mismo que a
elevada a la 3 x 3
así es que esto es déjame moverme un
poco hacia arriba esto es lo mismo que a
elevada a la potencia
3 por 3 que es igual a elevada a la
novena potencia ahora podemos
simplificar b por d cuadrada
vamos a simplificar este producto debe
por b cuadrada recuerda cuando tienes
veces constituidas de elevado a la 1
para calcular de a la 1 por ver cuadrada
tenemos que sumar los exponentes así que
ve a la 1 por b cuadrada es igual a b
elevada a la 12 que es igual a b
kubica finalmente de lo que podemos
simplificar a simple vista tenemos aquí
25 entre 525 entre 5 es igual a 5
es sacando quinta 25 nos da 5 sacando
quinta a 5 nos da 1 estamos dividiendo
tanto el numerador como el denominador
entre 5 ahora ya hemos simplificado
nuestra expresión a 5 que multiplica aa
la novena que multiplica a be cuadrada y
eso dividido entre a cuadrada
que multiplica a de kubica que
multiplica de kubica ahora podemos usar
la propiedad para el cociente de
exponentes tenemos a la novena entre a
cuadrada déjame usar otro color a la
novena entre a cuadrada y eso se
simplifica como vamos a escribirlo acá
abajo a la novena entre a cuadrada es
igual
a la 9 menos 2 y eso nos da igual a a
elevada a la séptima potencia ahora
también tenemos b cuadrada
sobre b cúbica esto se pone interesante
porque esto es entonces b cuadrada sobre
b kubica es igual a b elevado a la 2 - 3
y esto es igual a b elevada a la
potencia menos 1 y eso por lo pronto lo
vamos a dejar así y ahora ya hemos
simplificado nuestra expresión a 5 que
multiplica a
a la séptima como obtuvimos aquí a la
séptima y esto que multiplica lo que
hicimos aquí con las veces que es ve a
la menos 1 ahora podríamos haber dejado
la expresión así ya está simplificada
sin embargo no nos gusta este exponente
menos 1 así es que vamos a aplicar la
siguiente propiedad
véala menos 1 es igual a 1 entre b por
lo cual la expresión queda finalmente
como nuestro coeficiente 5 que
multiplica a
a séptima y eso que se multiplica por 1
entre b o lo que es lo mismo
/ / b que como vimos es equivalente a b
a la menos 1 y así hemos concluido